haha the Joe Rogan experience I remember
going to your house I would say there's
my one of my favorite stories the way I
met you is the last way you should meet
Joe I went up to your house you were at
the door already and you were like hey
man I go hey man big fan I got to see
the deprivation tank your dog in a pool
table then we need to get high and then
I'm ready to do this and you were like
caught off guard you're like okay you
took me back I met John I met Johnny
Cash took me down to the deprivation
tank we played around a pool went out to
that back where the swing set and the
chickens ended up being smoked a joint
red band showed up it changed my [ __ ]
life you said hey man you got to tell
that machine story every time you get on
stage if you hadn't done that
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'd be doing
if you you know that well that's what
happened that first night right so I
tell the machine story on to your
podcast and you go it's one of the best
stories it's one of that stories ever
told you go ladies and gentlemen
you go you tell on stage I go no you
know you gotta start Elemental stage hey
everybody and you talk to the co he is
from now on known as the Machine you
yelled a machine every one of his shows
until you tell make him tell it on stage
so I go to Columbus the next week I go
do my first show Thursday man like maybe
120 people not to not sold out and they
start chanting the Machine and I go hey
guys it's not a stage story this dude in
the front row des quad ride-or-die des
quad covered head to toe goes hobart we
understand it's not gonna be funny but
you've got to tell it if you're gonna
want it to be good so go ahead man come
on guys right right right and everyone
started cheering you can do a bird you
can do it I told him I told it make at
the bar they're like you we had to fake
last couple times but it's a big story
cut from that samandtom doing our
weight-loss challenge right the first
time we did our weight loss challenge
and that machine story went viral that
week that week that machine week you
guys did began the challenge or finish
the challenge the weigh-ins when he
shaved my beard really the machine story
went viral that [ __ ] week I say they
go they go you know you you I'm always
say I'm the luckiest dude in the world I
think I think I work hard I'm very very
very lucky I'm more lucky than anyone in
the world right just I stand by luck but
man the luckiest I've ever been is
making friends with a girl I remember
you telling me I remember you coming out
and saying I was I didn't want to make
friends you came out with the ship we
were at the ice house we're doing desk
Chronicles came out with a shot and a
beer you say hey you're good guy I go oh
yeah thanks you're like you know we're
all trying to be friend man and I was
like no I got it I get it
you're like no like like you just gotta
let us and I was like no I understand
you're like no no that means like when
we call you call us back and we and
you're like no I don't think it's there
you go me Joey
re Tommy we're all trying to be your
friend Bert but we have to tell you I
want I don't want to throw anybody under
the bus so as I explain this I'm gonna
be very careful okay the reason why
we're saying that because we know you
had been friends with a tyrant
[Laughter]
shell-shocked like Bert you were your
real friends like you [ __ ] scream
little you we actually liked you we're
gonna bust your balls but we bust every
one bus everyone's balls half the fun
that is a book you felt like a beaten
kid with Jesus Christ we got a light in
this crisis yeah I remember you guys
call one Saturday you go what are you
doing I go I'm on the treadmill and you
go nah come over the ice house and I
said oh I'm good and I hung up right and
then Tommy called me back and Tommy goes
hey man you gotta let us try to be your
friend
[ __ ] come to the Ice House just come
the [ __ ] ice house and I went and
then I heard you on the get earlier and
so I [ __ ] won over the ice Isles we
had a fun dude
[Applause]